[Music]
ding-ding-ding KOCO mobile unit inta
podcast you know where you are how many
feet isn't rolling up
he doesn't know how to count suppose I
was brought to you by post mates cuz you
craving Taco Bell right now cuz I feel
like I may be out of line here but I
feel like some of your craving Taco Bell
are you a mind reader are you psychic
listen okay I'm not gonna get into
details but I think you're craving Taco
Bell use cogent julián on post mates
it's a good thing okay and you can get
the Taco Bell you get $100 off free
delivery credit for your first 7 days so
use code you know Julie that's just our
names next to each other
download the post mates out and get food
use our names the end we've posted so
much food this weekend it's actually
like a really great thing for when
you're hosting mm-hmm like we had Jeff
Jeff and his girlfriend came over last
night we watched the fights together who
was awesome by the way
I [ __ ] love her she's pretty [ __ ]
love her her name's Rachel she was
making me laugh so hard
I think it's the first girlfriend of
Jeff that I've ever met yeah sorry we're
not trying to talk about you Jeff I love
you Jess we're talking about no we got
to hang out Jeff Jolene Rachel it was
fun but before you like they have you
know different diet dietary needs and
different food preferences than us so
you know I was like what what do you
mean which were you suit because it's
usually us that are the ones that are
like oh yeah no it's no problem just
can't eat anything yeah because he's
ketogenic and that's you know a very
specific diet so I was like what do you
eat he was like does this restaurant
deliver to you I was like yep Tom Post
mates this is where I want okay that's
it like I love to cook
it's like amazing then we can all sit
meet me all send me but like whatever
we're supposed to eat you know it's
lovely
so we're alive the earthquake didn't
kill us were Sadie's we've had so many
people reach out and like also on
Twitter just messages all kind of all
over the place yeah thank you guys for
that thank you thoughtful and kind I've
also talked to both of my parents same
say my brother
yeah I talked to my mom so we were on
stream there's actually a clip we were a
streaming live when the second
earthquake hit which was the bigger one
well I'm too drugged with the first one
fourth of July one rerun the first
earthquake we were in bed slowly loafing
our way awake and it hit and we start
feeling it and it's just like it just
kind of feels like things are just like
slowly shaking you're like okay there's
an earthquake and we look at Bunny's
case you should just stand it up do the
thing what was she doing she was doing
the know that who was the little Kim Kim
that's a bunny looked like she was just
standing in her crate and just like
what's up she wasn't scared though she
was just like curious like the
earthquakes never scared bunny in fact
when the second one hit we were you were
very concerned about like her yeah we
were streaming live I took my headset
off you took your headset off and you
went right to bunny we're like bunny
it's okay it's okay but she was like
cool she was okay but it was it was
gnarly so the first one hit and it was
like shaky shaky be like damn that was
an earthquake but it wasn't like really
scary or anything we just kind of felt
it it was like okay we thought that I
feel like that's the kind that I've felt
since I've lived in Southern California
where it's a little short and then it's
over and then you're like okay and it
never feels like it's increasing it's
all just this like steady shake shake
dead but then the second one came when
we were streaming and that one was
gnarly because not fun it was not fun
it was the wave it's very very very
difficult to describe what it feels like
to experience an earthquake like that to
anyone who hasn't experienced it there's
no real way to relate it to another
experience in life it's like the earth
is [ __ ] shaking like nothing that you
think matters matters anymore because
the earth is shaking and you like you
don't know when it's gonna stop you
don't know if it's gonna get worse you
don't know you just don't know anything
and you feel so small and insignificant
so it was shaking it was shaking my mic
arm was going like this the camera was
shaking on stream and we look outside
and the pool is just like this [ __ ]
rapid
there's like waves and it's crashing
over it was just bizarre
and then it started to get a little
crazier it was like a little bit
increased in the middle there and and
you know it got kind of spooky and then
it slowly died down but it lasted close
to a minute for us
yeah and I've I'm 27 have been in
Southern California all 27 years my life
that was the worst one I've experienced
and you were a baby in the 94 north I
was a baby in the 94 Northridge
earthquake so technically I've
experienced worse but I don't remember
it because I was 2 years old after that
earthquake though they did a lot of
retrofitting in like santa monica and
other areas like where you grew up which
is a good thing yeah you know they go
into old buildings or like parking
structures especially are pretty
vulnerable they've retrofit a lot of
those because the damage of the 94
earthquake was from what I've read this
was not fun for a lot of people and
people lost their homes and you know
that was an early one no and and we like
for 4 or 5 years ago Jen and I used to
live in Westwood and there was an
earthquake where the epicenter was
Westwood so we were on top of the
epicenter yeah so when we were talking
about how the dogs reacted during that
Westwood earthquake which was I think
only like a four or something like that
but when the epicenter is under you like
listen I'm not a size Matala
I'm not a seismologist the way you
mixologist I'm a mixologist but when the
earthquake is pretty shallow or
obviously if you're closer to the
epicenter it's more violent shaking like
I've seen a lot of clips obviously of
earthquakes on Twitter and the internet
you know when people are at the
epicenter it is very violent it is very
terrifying and it can make a for feel
like a 9:00 exactly
and um well not really but sort of well
I mean yeah well it feels like a much
more intense number on the Richter scale
when you're close yeah because it was a
seven point one magnitude earthquake the
one that we had but because we're a
hundred miles away from the epicenter it
didn't feel that bad but for those
people that are near that
terrible terrible and you see videos of
like the liquor store and things like
that where things are just completely
thrown everywhere you're like okay well
that's the epicenter so the one in
Westwood that we had the epicenter was
literally in Westwood and it was only
about a four but that was that was the
one where the guy jumps under the desk
on the news station yeah that was that
one yeah and if an earthquake is more
shallow
it feels very shaky and very vibrating
and if it's pretty deep it's that those
are like the rocking ones but the the
one in Westwood was either kind of
shallow or just like directly underneath
us because the shaking was very violent
yeah it was like vibrate it woke us up
out of our sleep and that's when the
dogs all started barking they're like
freaking out that's that's the kind of
one more like all of your stuff is
making noise like everything is rattling
yeah yeah yeah but the one that we had
is like the scene in the superhero movie
when the bad guys flying in and it's
just right the one that we had the other
day if the closest thing I could compare
it to is being on a rocking moving ship
but like you're rocking pretty fast and
there is the most eerie thing about that
is that there is no sound other than
your house making noise and our pool
splashing there's no sound so like the
world it just sounds quiet everything
sounds silent but then you'll hear like
the door was open so the door was sort
of like slapping the doorframe and like
so the dogs aren't alert they're not
like Oh things are falling but I was
afraid that you know we've seen bunny
when she gets in that anxious state
she'll run into the yard like we don't
know what she would do if she would try
and jump out of the yard like it's it's
scary so I wanted to make sure that she
was okay because it's right on top these
guys might start barking we already know
what they don't know what bunny is in it
yeah so I was pretty nervous for her
because the first one she was in her
crate which made me feel a little better
yes she's doing a little Kim dance in
there but that one because the door was
open I was afraid that she was gonna
start panicking and I don't know where
she would go it's very difficult to you
know like she was great
in the fireworks we're lucky enough to
live in a place where it's dry and we
have hella fires though people aren't
really out here light and a lot of fire
there are still some but not nearly as
much as like properly well we kept the
door closed and just made sure that
there was like sound in the room and
bunny was totally fine she didn't want
to go to the bathroom outside during
that like you know 7:00 to 10:00 p.m.
hmm
which I didn't blame her but yeah we
didn't have a problem at all but I do
think if we were in a place where there
were loud fireworks she would not enjoy
them but yeah it was it's [ __ ] scary
obviously that's the largest earthquake
that I've been in since I've lived here
yeah right though I mean now thinking
back to the west water it was very
different this one was a slow shaking
ship as a good is a good way to describe
it but it was still but it's the world
it was yeah like [ __ ] man it's not just
like your desk moving or like the Shelf
moving it's like your whole [ __ ]
house and your pool and the ground
underneath you and your cars in the
garage things like that it's just like
[ __ ] I think the scariest thing about an
earthquake to me is that like we have a
plan you know and we have a go-bag and
we have you know a basic understanding
of what you should do in an earthquake
which is what most people try their best
to have but an earthquake comes at any
time anywhere so you could have a plan
and then be at a Shawn Mendes conscious
concert and all of a sudden it's like
now you don't have a plan at least some
[ __ ] going down style you some people
tweeting that they were at the Shawn
Mendes oh whether it happy okay you're
in this massive room full of people like
what's your plan now or you run to the
grocery store you're at a movie theater
I saw a lot of people had a movie
theater yeah you know did you see the
video of that restaurant in the
epicenter yeah that was pretty crazy
yeah the light fixtures were swinging
and then you saw people start to panic a
little bit and run around that that to
me is more of a scary situation than
anything is being in a public place with
other people not only like aside from
the fact that you might not be with your
loved ones right you're in a public
place amongst other strangers who may be
reacting poorly or whatever
to a situation like that which just
might make everything kind of worse like
I saw in that video people were yelling
and running and maybe not being like as
I don't mentally prepared or calm or
whatever as it calm it is it is but it's
like it also that sort of behavior can
like induce more of it it can create
more panic and so I don't know that that
video is creepy because of the light
fixtures but also just because it's like
[ __ ] I forgot what people can like
people do sometimes it's hard to stay
calm yeah well especially since you know
when the fourth of July wouldn't
happened it was like oh it's just an
earthquake you know and then you you
immediately go on Twitter you look where
the epicenter is is this the San Andreas
Fault no what's going on
it was the surly I don't know what it's
called this matter so then when we had
the second one it's on the same fault
line so now as of now we still have one
and is a one in tenth I don't know her
name is dr. Lucy something else
something yeah dope yeah says we have
about a 1 in 10 or 1 in 20 chance of
having a larger earthquake Jones Lucy
Jones yeah but we have a 9 out of 10
chance that that was the earthquake and
we're done today she tweeted a day or
two after every big earthquake of my
career we hear rumors that an even
bigger earthquake is going to happen but
we are denying it to avoid a panic this
rumor is no more true than it was after
Northridge landers or Hector mine
there's also always someone who claims
they know a big quake is coming this is
not a scientific assessment Lucy out
here spitting facts right so because the
4th of July would happen on that fault
line and then a larger one occurred on
the same fault line the biggest one now
becomes the earthquake and the July 4th
one is considered the for shock if we
were to have a bigger earthquake on that
same fault line then that becomes the
earthquake and the two previous are the
four shocks but anything after today if
it's smaller is considered an aftershock
so hopefully that one was considered the
earthquake and that would not get in a
bigger one than that because I'm all
I can set you feel me yeah yeah and I
actually just posted a picture of kind
of a flat lay image with labels of our
go back and I might go over right now I
think that might actually be kind of
good to talk about I don't know people
seemed interested to know what will be
packed in our in our emergency safety Go
Bag where you have a bag packed for
emergencies like an earthquake any sort
of a disaster fire blackout anything
like that and so basically when the
earthquake happened on the 5th Jen and I
we were like I said we were live on
stream we took a pretty long BRB we
pause stream and and buffed the go back
and kind of walked ourselves through the
plan a little bit madrenas fridge moved
a couple things around we have a fridge
like a mini fridge on a desk in the game
rooms all the madrenas coffee
so we lo we put it on the floor and
taped it shut because the last thing we
want and the [ __ ] earthquake is for a
fridge full of coffee to slam on the
ground right next to our dog who we
rescued right it's right by bunny which
is why we put it on the ground and then
taped it um but I mean we all stripped
hide some of our kitchen cabinets yes
clothes and then when we had company
last night I was like let me cut these
zip ties off so I could get you some
water but I'll give you I'll give you a
little like a short rundown of like what
we have and some of them I've kind of
put put in there on my own accord and
some of them I've looked up for being
like good things to having a go back but
so we have a fanny pack and inside the
fanny pack I have things like a
multi-tool spare car key pliers
batteries zip ties a knife lighter
deodorant phone cables external power
and a can opener a little low-profile
can opener we just got we have spare
glasses for Jenna and contacts we have a
car AC adapter we have dog food dog
calming juice and spare dog leashes and
harnesses we have a travel mug where the
handle is actually a carabiner so we can
clip onto things your spare shoes spare
garbage bags we have two large tarps
which i think is a pretty huge thing to
have and i go back because it's super
cheap to buy and
doesn't take up much space in the bag
but in a situation where you need to
stay dry like those are very important
types of Pilates
a lot of uses tarps and duct tape we
have had 95 respirators which I kept I
bought a box for when the fires happened
and we kept them so we put a bunch in
the go bag we have some water bottles
and then we have self filtering water
bottle canteens where it's like you can
fill it up with river water and it
filters it so you can drink it we have
tablets aqua tablets which purify water
spare contact lenses I already got that
hermits meds some spare cash mixed nuts
like a giant couple of bags of mixed
nuts which peach has gotten into a
couple beats the peach has found her way
into the go bag so now when emergencies
are afoot we have to also watch out for
our food driven dog to not ruin
everything
we have cans of beans peanut butter we
have this lantern that is crank powered
and it also serves as a USB charger so
in a situation where you have zero power
and zero external batteries you can
crank charge the lantern and not only
will it provide light but it provides
juice that you can plug your phone into
so that's really nice then another
Lantern a couple of flashlights feminine
products ibuprofen freeze-dried dog food
freeze-dried dog food oh yeah
freeze-dried is important to know yeah
so it stays good umbrella and that's
kind of it I mean you know we're
sleeping bag - yeah so not in the bag
there's a sleeping bag a tent a dog
crate that we can take with us and
lately like the Go Bag is right there
yeah we've been taking it with us to
every single room in the house that we
go to so if we go to bed we bring it to
our bedroom if you go to the stream
you're putting in the stream room go
just because we're on high alert
earthquake watch which by the way buddy
is right here and we were talking about
the other day like we kind of have an
ideal situation for if anything were to
happen because we're all always in the
same room yeah so yeah but I mean that's
you know even that's scary as well it's
like okay you we have a plan for each
room of our house because we're usually
all together in this
you know of a heavy desk or table or
something to get under for the most part
yeah but you know you could just go
upstairs and be in the shower it's just
it's a wild concept I know it's a wild
natural disaster where all of a sudden
everything you've planned for is like
doesn't [ __ ] matter
you're in the bathtub what are you into
I know like you spent all this time
planning and prepping you're like I'm
gonna run to the store real quick and
then there was quite kids crazy men but
you know there's one thing that you
can't pack into go back and it's just
really enjoy those plates will bring you
pizza though even when there's an
earthquake post meat doesn't care or
earthquake be like shake post mates be
like okay what do you want to eat to in
so if you guys are hungry in an
earthquake or not in an earthquake also
use post mates to deliver the food that
you love to your mouth with code Jen and
Jillian hundred dollars off delivery
charges the first seven days check it
out
and get pizza and get Taco Bell I'm not
reading your mind but you definitely
want both of those foods right now don't
look into my eyes who doesn't look into
my eyes Julianne what phone lines are
down right why there's no power you have
your phone and you just you know you
can't call anyone but you like you can
you got internet what the hell post
mates 365 days er even during this quick
Jen you just go on post mates if you've
never used the app you go on post mates
and you type in your address
don't worry that wall talks you and it
tells you in your area what restaurants
and establishments they can pick up food
from and bring it to you so you can eat
it it's super easy you see the post mate
on a little map so you can see how far
they are and if you need to have a snack
to tide you over you're like they're
gonna be here in like ten minutes on
your snack
I'll be ok so then the food gets there
and you eat it all and then you're like
earthquake earthquake I just got fed
I don't even know how to respond to the
things that you're saying right now use
post base code enjoy thank you post
mates no thanks to you Julian all thanks
to me and passé but mainly me no mainly
post mates
anyway so we're good everybody's good
and yeah it wasn't wasn't my favorite
thing but yeh yeah I hope you sign up
for when you live in yeah I guess all of
California really it is a scary thing
though I mean like I gotta say like you
know we're together mm-hmm
you and me and then we're all together
with the dogs but like being alone in
something like that I can imagine is a
pretty startling and unsettling
experience so I feel for those of you
who are in Southern California alone who
might have had to go through that alone
and and kind of self soothe self sooth a
little bit and and tell yourself you
know it's it's scary and this is like
literally the most like insignificant
you could ever feel because it's like
when the earth shakes you don't matter
you don't know what's gonna happen and
that's a scary feeling especially when
you don't have someone to like sit there
with you or hug or hold you know so I
hope everyone's okay if you're in
Southern California hope everything you
know is safe and sound for you but yeah
keep on high alert get together even if
it's not a go-bag like of that size gets
get a little backpack with a couple of
supplies just to have tuck it away in
your closet or somewhere where you can
grab it and go in a situation just a
flashlight first-aid kit battery you
know stuff like that where you just
you're not completely empty-handed in a
situation you know where you might want
to just have a couple things yeah well
I'll tell you I mean we have blackouts
and stuff in the summer because of the
heat and every time the power goes out
all of a sudden Julian's like be right
back he's got like four lanterns so you
just cranks a few times and he looks
like turns them on he's like here we go
baby late where he overpowered you need
ammo fee got ammo fee got ammo fee here
you need some charging like we're
it's so ready for anything that happens
it's really fun it's kind of a fun thing
I don't know I enjoy it when the power
goes out when you're completely ready I
imagine it's pretty fun you're like
Showtime well no no I don't mean I don't
mean any natural disaster it's fun I
mean when you like you sort of treat
like emergency prep as a hobby a little
bit right so you like you take pride in
like what you're getting to prepare
what's going in the back and like how to
use everything and you go through the
drills and it becomes like oh I enjoy
flashlights or I enjoy the own devices
little things like that so yeah so all
good we're safe but we do have power
right this that's how we're able to
record this podcast but it's also how
we're able to watch Nicholas Cage movies
okay I do not know what happened I don't
know what happened but all of a sudden
we I'd like it was out of the blue I
literally was like we should watch some
Nicolas Cage movies you or someone who
has ideas like that that make no sense
there is no understanding where they
come from
yeah but they happen regularly but
they're all really good ideas but the
thoughts like I feel like I have a
normal train of thought
like all day every day for the most part
and then every once in a while I have
one that just sort of like shoots down
that's the only way to describe it but
Kurt just shots it shoots down at me it
comes from up here somewhere and it
shoots down like all my thoughts are
linear and then I get one that's
completely verdict you have a thought
Zeus in your brain he shoots a thought
he takes his spear and he just Chuck's
it at my head it's like watch Nicolas
Cage movies but I always said like and
I'm a person how many movies do I like
to watch none never a movie I don't like
watching you these Jedi won't let me
I've I've watched so many of your
favorite movies I've watched Wicker Park
I've watched my best friend's wedding I
watched so many movies that like you
were just like you have to watch the
movie I love this movie it means so much
to me and you won't even sit down and
watch Remember the Titans with me trying
to get you watch that movie for years we
haven't like picked a time but we can
but that's true you have been a very
good sport and watched a lot
movies but to be fair I've seen stuck on
you so I mean it's not like I haven't
watched yet you're welcome thank you
i I just I got like a zoo s' spear to my
brain it was like I need to watch every
Nicollet listen every Nicolas Cage movie
ever made
why so I go on Netflix one night and I'm
like Julian we should we should just
watch every Nicolas Cage movie every
minute and you're like okay so every
night we go to Netflix or Hulu or
whatever we have I just type in Nicolas
Cage and the body of work is astounding
it's beautiful there are so many it's a
thing of absolute beauty so we started
with like national treasure which I
while I was watching that in some of
these Nicolas Cage movies I decided the
reason why I get so frustrated watching
a lot of movies is because I only like
two types of movies incredible movies or
horrible movies it has to be either like
it really makes me feel something it
like it really blows my mind or it is
the worst thing I've ever seen that's it
I can't watch a mediocre film it makes
me mad that's perfect for Nic Cage
that's what I feel like he's either made
really incredible movies or it was just
the worst thing I've ever seen like
national treasure to me is like when we
watched paul blart mall cop it is like
almost so bad but it's so enjoyable yeah
I love it I love national treasure in
America there are hundreds of plot holes
first it is a sieve of bottles you can
put your pasta in it and strain it with
the amount of plot holes in that film
yeah it's um but you're right it's
enjoyable because it's like I love my
favorite scene that I just comes to mind
is when they go to Paris or yeah they go
to Paris I think and they fly this like
helicopter drone at this like mini
Statue of Liberty to look at the to look
at the writing and he's flying this like
clunky helicopter this is like in what
2005-2006 I don't know
I don't know and he's like enhance all
the way in probably like the equivalent
of like a 200 millimeter like focal
length and it's like crystal-clear and
he's flying this like the shaky ass
helicopter it's just like oh my God he's
remote flying a helicopter God my I
think my favorite fake movie thing is
enhance enhance we've hacked the
mainframe yeah enhance enhance what is
how are you enhancing footage how are
you
increasing resolution after it's been
filmed and why is the focus voice
command operated why can you just say
the word enhance and it focuses and
zooms in it's not real watch national
treasure than watch national treasure
too in big secrets which I realize I've
already seen both of them yeah I first
some reason I've seen both of those
films already me the person that doesn't
watch see national treasure 1 & 2 and
they're both super lit and so then we
took a trip down a completely different
Road meryl streep Avenue and watched
adaptation and my god that is a roller
coaster of a movie I really liked it so
my only memory of adaptation and I think
this Rachel said this last night is all
that you remember is that billboard the
more he say where he's laying on a side
and his head is a plant right up like a
broken planter with soil and whatever
and I never saw it I remember I was a
child or young when it came out and I
would look it I remember actually the
intersection where the billboard was it
was on Bundy and Wilshire and I would
see it I mean like that's [ __ ] weird
adults like weird movies you know cuz
it's like my dad would watch it and that
was my only memory of it so we were like
let's watch adaptation and oh my god
like how do you even there's so much to
say about that movie the best I could
relate that movie to is it's it's got
the same vibe as Burn After Reading
which was I love that movie but it's so
[ __ ] weird and random and makes kind
of no sense sometimes but it's just like
a very weird vibe
and there are things that happen you're
like what and then things happen all at
once and Nic Cage plays - Nick cages
he pays him and his twin brother and for
some reason every scene he's talking to
his twin brother his twin brother
sitting on the floor like sitting on the
floor it's it was great
it was aware of itself I don't care but
I don't care yeah was there was there
was a meta aspect to it I don't
appreciate that I don't care about the
film I want to watch Nicolas Cage's body
of work that film was good I enjoyed
myself it was I enjoyed myself about
orchids I really liked it which as the
lover of plants it was great got Meryl
Streep is sometimes a little funny gets
very [ __ ] meta at the end loved it
good time but I feel like in the 90s we
all thought Nicolas Cage was this
seriously talented actor we were talking
about this last night I feel like in the
90s and like parts of the 2000s right
you have these actors that are on top of
the world there's the if it's like your
dad's like oh there's a new Nicolas Cage
movie out we're gonna watch we should we
should go watch it no because you just
rely on the actor to carry the movie
which is like that old Hollywood model
it's like you're there we need someone
to headline this film to put the asses
in the seats you know so let's get
Nicolas Cage and then people are like oh
I bet it's probably good it's Nicolas
Cage right so these people walk around
they have the biggest ego so they can do
whatever they want they paid millions of
dollars and you know the worst criticism
they might face is like a movie critic
right loser on the internet or some
people might say it wasn't very good but
doesn't matter good book another movie
yeah you know they might make a couple
bad movies but they're still Julia
Roberts you know you'll still get
another job after that what why yeah
which one is that no I got it yeah for
sure but I feel like in the 90s we all
thought he was like this incredible
actor which he is yeah but we thought
all of it was an act until you look at
my Nicholas Cage it's work and you're
like what's he actually acting during
any of that if some of this just not
acting at all it's just Nicolas
age what's that the YouTube video that
we love so much Nicolas Cage freak out
Nicolas Cage freak out compilation yes
so he's like yelling and screaming and I
was like imagine being a screenwriter
right like this
this film is your baby like you you
write this film there like right we got
a big we got a big actor attached to is
it's Nicolas Cage you bring them in and
you do 10 takes of this one scene that
you've written very clearly it's just
like yelling and screaming and doing
these things and we're like I guess we
got it I mean it's not what I wrote or
efficient at all but think when he
screams the ABCs Jake you're like yeah I
mean I just wrote ABC and that was it
but we launched the whole compilation
and we were watching with Jeff and
really none of that was written that was
written in the script like there's a
scene where he punches Kathy Bates he
slowly walks up to her and punches her
it's just like I don't know it's he's
one of a kind
he is truly one of a kind anyway so at
we watch our tation and I don't like
that I was enjoying I know I know I'm
just trying to watch Nick I know I know
I'm saying we watched adaptation now we
watched the humanity humanity Bureau
she's on Netflix oh my god what is that
movie I will say it came out 2017
there's only two years ago I will say
some of some of it was good looking like
some of the shots were pretty beautiful
I like the way someone who is color
grading I'm trying to go posit at first
some of those calibrated color grading
cool
the the locations they chose to shoot
out were nice but that's not it's not
even the worst movie I've ever seen
oh it is no no it is no no you need to
understand that you're wrong
and it is the worst movie you've ever
seen now it is such horrible writing the
it's like it's like someone who worked
at Toys R Us was like here use this gun
okay and action and they were all just
like they like no one knew had to hold a
gun that was barely it was completely
immersion breaking there was no there
was no situation where I felt like
anyone who was holding a gun was
supposed to be ever holding a gun
they're all like these sue
for secret agents so tell them what he
does to the kid so this kid is on the
roof so he's he he for some the premise
of the movie is he like falls for this
woman he's like he works for this like
secret agent it's like this
post-apocalyptic world where he goes out
to these people who are still living in
this like desolate land that used to be
America and he's like are you
contributing to society and he looks at
their [ __ ] and they're like yes I am and
he's like no you're not
kills him or whatever so he goes to this
like lady's house and with no sort of
like dialogue or chemistry or anything
he just is in love with her and so
that's the movie right like he's just
with her
um spoilers I'm not gonna tell this be
trying to watch this until the spoilers
since it's only a two year old movie I'm
getting there
let me get them given a little synopsis
may i synopsize porfavor so he's at this
woman's house she has the son the son
decides hey I'm a son I'm gonna climb up
onto the roof because that's what sons
do so he climbs up onto the roof falls
through the roof is unconscious right so
he Nick Cage runs outside he looks at
the kid he's unconscious tries to give
him mouth to mouth mouth mouth yeah he
know mouth-to-mouth
he didn't give the boy mouth-to-mouth he
did like CPR where he like did his chest
oh maybe it was CPR but anyway he
listened he like put his ear to his
mouth and he did CPR and nothing was
working the kid was just like laying
there so he sits the kid up and smacks
him on the back and the kid wakes up
he's like hey I'm okay like he didn't
spit anything out he wasn't choking he
just got slapped in that fell off the
roof of a house well everyone knows that
when you fall off a house you did need
to get slapped away age style slapped in
the back like basically just woke the
[ __ ] up mm-hmm
god damn it dude and I I swear to god he
called like a full full-on assault rifle
glock at one point i think that happened
anyway sorry but it's it's it i just
want to watch every nic cage also they
use the green screen in every car seat
they did they're driving a car he
just doing this it's like an old-time
old-timey movie you know and the green
screens in the back it's like what what
why would someone do that it changes it
doesn't even feel even remotely real
sorry I don't it's just there's
something interesting to me about about
him as a person and him as an actor like
I read the headline the other day
isn't the title of this podcast can be
called earthquakes and Nic Cage the
headline was Nicolas Cage seen hanging
out with his third wife shortly after
divorcing his fourth way and it's fun
and then you saw the headline knows it
was a reddit post ok rage walking with
the Sun but looks like his son's
imaginary friend and his sons like you
know wearing normal clothes like holding
like IDs or something in Nicolas Cage is
wearing a top hat and a cane looks like
it like off-brand Willy Wonka weird but
I'm just interested to see a person's
entire body of work because you know at
some point he was this huge box office
like very talented well-respected actor
and I want to see like just what
happened yeah and through your 20 19
wins like what does it look like now
yeah cuz he's still highly respected in
acting like no one's like man that guy
can't access the works absolutely not
and I just think it's interesting
sometimes you you take jobs like that
that you are like that sounds like a
cool concept or like maybe you like the
script and some of them are very good
like I watched another one while you
fell asleep with Elijah Wood thinking is
called the trust and some of this
[ __ ] sound design and that like some
of the cinematography like really
[ __ ] good you know but I've never
heard of this film before I don't know
anybody that's seen it and he's you know
amazing and it's just cool yeah you see
someone's career in like maybe figure
out why they said yes to do that movie
like is it purely because you need a
paycheck this year like you don't care
you like the concept or I don't know
what it is I see you're just cool I see
your point and it makes me [ __ ] laugh
yeah
I get your point of watching the whole
body of work from an actor and I also
kind of am starting to understand where
the bolt came from of watching Nick
cages body you've worked because I feel
like you are a person who likes to look
deeper into like memes sometimes right
and look past like why it's funny and
maybe just like let's just understand
everything about it yeah that's what you
are you're an analytic person you're
like I need to understand every single
thing about this person or situation to
make it all clear for me and to be
perfectly honest Nick Cage is kind of a
perfect subject for that he makes me
laugh really because he's like Nick Cage
it's like why not watch his whole
filmography and understand like when he
when he was this and when he turns into
that and like what what it all looked
like and watch it now yeah it's very
entertaining
I mean we're watching the movies every
night we'll turn on in the Cage movie so
I'm catching like depending on how tired
I am half a movie to like a quarter of
it the humanity bro Bureau I made it
pretty much the whole thing you know the
next day or the two days later yeah try
and pick up where we left office only
we're watching a movie every night but
we have a lot of movies to go we have a
lot of comics I mean what's so fun about
it though is that you can just type it
into anywhere and there's just like
their clothes kids a bunch of Nicolas
Cage movies that you can watch for free
if you have Netflix or a streaming
service you don't mean it's fun yeah
Oh Knight Rider I can't wait till we get
them they'll face off Connor
I'd never seen face off dude it's it's
about to go down I'm like there's so
many action films gone in 60 seconds
like and then he I feel like there's a
high volume in which he's playing like a
cop yeah with a moustache it's almost
like he said to his agent I want to be a
cop but I'm an actor make me a cop as
much as you can I've seen like the
Wickerman like I saw some of that stuff
I feel like that's where man was when
people started being like all right Nic
Cage we're not just go see whatever the
[ __ ] you make and take it down a notch
guy it got pretty bad read that when he
punches Kathy Bates know that what he
says the bees that's the bees that's
that's how to get burned how do you fern
how to get burned how to get burned that
one
I don't know I I just I'm interested to
watch every Nicholas Cage movie that's
ever made and report back to you on my
findings that's my current study next
week we're having Nick Cage on the
podcast let's just get a cut out of Nick
Cage and put it right well our trainer
but sound trader Justin Nicolas Cage's
onboard our trainer dustin has like this
sick [ __ ] pinup tattoo on his arm and
it's a pinup doll tattoo just like a
full-size girl like yeah you know and
it's like pretty old like he's clearly
had it for a very long time and he I
guess wasn't like a super fan of how the
face looked which is incredibly
difficult to tattoo so he had had it
just laser dogfaces lasered off so the
whole pinup is there but there's no face
right it's black and gray so it's it
doesn't it's not like a color picture
with no face it's not creepy at all it's
like the tattoos relatively faded and he
was like you guys got any ideas when I
could put there and even before I
started all this I was like Nicolas
Cage's face because the the legs sort of
poked out in his shirtsleeves so you can
see her legs and her lower body but if
you just pulled it up and it was just
Nicolas Cage's face like that is a
[ __ ] tattoo is a dope-ass tattoo I
would why if I had Nicolas Cage on my
brain for this long what's going on
what's going on Ben I'm just it's the
most fun I've had watching movies in a
while I just cannot wait to see the next
Nicolas Cage film you just don't know
what you're gonna get no life is like a
box of Nicolas Cage movies you just
never know what you're gonna get but you
know it's about to get wild at one point
yeah yeah Wow Wow maybe several points
so we'll keep you posted on our
endeavors into the Nicolas Cage's sphere
leave into the Nick into the Nicolas
Cage Wow leave your favorite Nicolas
Cage movie in the comments or or don't
it's the Nicolas Cage Jenna and Julie
enter only one will win has he done any
like rom-coms I desperately wanted yeah
sure hope his filmography I'm Nicolas
Cage rom-com I want to see him in a role
other than like a cop cuz that's what
I've seen primarily at this point okay
let's let's look at this on IMDB okay
filmography known for a face off I know
he's done a couple of horror films he
was in the Croods oh no he's in the
Croods - I spoiled it he's in a movie
called you Jitsu oh my god we have to
watch okay Julian he wait a minute he's
in he was into the spider-verse he was
the spider-man noir that makes perfect
sense it makes for I remember listening
about me like that's Nic Cage
that's dope oh my god we have to watch
jujitsu okay I feel like you should
what's that rabbit or something where
people can watch films with you rabbit
it's called rabbit that's something that
you should we've never even used that
it's a website where you can watch
movies I don't know if all the movies
are on there you watch movies and you
can like it's like twitch streaming
there's because I desperately want to
group watch jiu-jitsu with you while you
react to judo we should do it we should
totally do that
how can we legally do that I think
rabbit makes makes that legal I don't
know how it works but I think look into
it look that would be a fun activity
he's drugged in the Kreutz he was in the
cruise and the cruise - which is coming
next year Grug
I don't remember forget who that is but
the cruise is one of our favorite movies
I love it love the cruise ghostrider
obviously Drive Angry
wait what I thought you were looking on
Brahm coms Oh
kick-ass no that's not a rom-com mmm
Bangkok dangerous is that a rom-com
[Laughter]
yeah I don't see any matchstick men like
the glory days of the 90s we're gonna
keep going back
all these are like the 2000s it could
happen to you isn't that a [ __ ]
you're asking the king of not seeing
them so maybe City of Angels that's it
that's the one with the Meg meg Ryan
that's the one I'm thinking of do you
remember that movie know that Goo Goo
Dolls song absolutely not but these are
like [ __ ] films man I mean it's it's
a body of work it's incredible that is a
body of work while that heart looks like
a rom-com we are on jitsu vampires kiss
is that the I'm a vampire I want to
watch these old ones these look so good
how do we find them do we live here a
blockbuster Valley he's in a film called
valley girl okay you know what we should
so excited we should illegally pirate
all of these movies and sell it has the
Nic Cage movie collection sit down and
watch it with your friends I just want
to see what the synopsis of this movie
is yeah please tell us what this is no I
don't want the IMDB app plot summary a
new sci-fi martial arts franchise from
Dmitry Logothetis director producer of
kick boxer retaliation just what I want
to see this is I can't why'd you just
who could be a b-movie fans dream come
true oh we're b-movie fans that's what I
are no no no no lower than that movie I
want an F movie I want to see who else
is oh oh I can't wait to watch this he's
got a beard in it wait are there any
actual like race letters yeah um
probably I'm not recognizing any of them
though I'm not recognizing any of the
cast actually which makes me so excited
I'm just gonna discover so much what I
watch do you did you with Nick Cage you
didn't find like the synopsis damn I
think we'll leave it up to honestly it's
gonna be drives I think we should do
this on rabbit yeah we should we could
figure out a way we should watch it - a
rabbit that'd be so fun I'd honestly
watch a lot of Nick Cage movies on
rabbit it would be so fun be pretty
great group watch Nick Cage movies we
should do that friends what do you say
join us on our quest let's make it a
popcorn for everyone yeah yeah yeah yeah
bring your popcorn I I can't believe it
but I think this might be my favorite
podcast we were done earthquakes and Nic
Cage movies oh yeah
best podcasts ever I think he's becoming
my favorite actor at this point I'm
learning new things what what's wrong
with Nicolas Cage being my favorite
actor not a goddamn thing I'll tell you
one thing what she's just so he's gonna
be my favorite person that's that's what
I'm saying all right well if you don't
have popcorn you can postmates it use
cogent and Julian will actually look
into doing the thing on rabbit I don't
know if all the movies in the world are
available for it or how that even works
I hoped you jitsu starring Nicolas Cage
is on there or also I'm gonna be
devastated if not I'll just say [ __ ] it
and download it and then watch it on
stream on Twitch Julian watch you Jitsu
on Twitch what can't do that come on
they don't even know about twitch the
director of jiu-jitsu he's directing
jiu-jitsu to the streets right now
there's no idea about 22 Furious
two Jet's too furious it's like fast and
furious but they're just running while
they're grappling then the middle of a
Tokyo Street they're running and
grappling the same just choking each
other while sprinting
on the street oh god what have we done
we've enjoyed ourselves that's correct
oh you woke up don't see that's why
they're unbothered during an earthquake
cuz you're just cause you don't like
bumping them around prepping them that's
what I'm doing Julian no okay you know
what I I have jujitsu to watch I have to
go okay fine
me too what do you think I'm noon later
why didn't you did say what do you think
I'm doing in the morning not going to
jujitsu watch the new Jitsu men um thank
you guys for hanging out and listening
and watching her another podcast thank
you also for letting us take off last
week for the 4th of July
hmm we'll be back next week and we'll be
live on stream all week on Twitch and
maybe rabbit who knows please crazier
things that happen I hope so
be good be more like Nick Cage everyday
and be safe if you're in Southern
California get your go bags ready see
you guys next week
[Music]
you
[Music]